any changes today the younger security
officer Zach asked as he stepped into
the Watchtower that is if replied is
superior a jaded cynical old man who
insisted on being referred to as Mr
Jefferson a darn thing hasn't moved
spoken or done so much as stretch one of
those wings of his another day at the
office then Zach Jones through the
window the pair of them looked through
at the Towering figure a few kilometers
away
scp-001 the gate Guardian stood
motionless its fiery sword in its hand
ever protecting its post at the
precipice between our world and Paradise
it had long been stationed at the
entrance of a dimensional Gateway that
led to what was believed to be the
Garden of Eden described in the biblical
Old Testament much like the security
officers in the foundation's base tasked
with watching The Guardian this was
pretty much the extent of the day's
activities hey did you see that news
about the transfer posting Zach asked
trying to Stave off boredom with as much
conversation he could squeeze out of his
fellow officer yeah I saw it Mr
Jefferson scoffed rolling his eyes what
possesses someone like Robert Montauk to
come down here and must have wanted a
quieter post Zach recent looking out at
the Stillness of the gate Guardian won't
find one any quieter than here Jefferson
mused I'm showing up will be the most
exciting thing that's happened here in a
long while unbeknownst to both Zach and
Mr Jefferson Dr Robert Montauk would be
only joining the team at the gate
Guardian observation site for a short
while not one of them nor anybody else
within the foundation could ever guess
montauk's true intentions behind
venturing there in the first place he
wanted an audience with a gay Guardian
itself approaching the Colossal thousand
foot tall being Dr Montauk crossed the
threshold of the minimum safe distance
from the guardian given the sheer heat
of its weapon hotter than Earth's sun
anything within a kilometer of scp-001
was at risk of being obliterated
vaporized into atoms if they didn't turn
back which through a voice that
immediately rang out in montauk's ears
the gate Guardian commanded him to do
it's psychic message boomed wait wait Dr
Montauk urged holding up his hands in
what would have been a futile defense
against the Guardian Sword I know what
you do when people don't listen to your
commands but please just give me a
minute it was silence
scp-001 didn't reply there was nobody
else close enough to hear Montauk speak
to it so he continued you are impossibly
old we know that much about you and
because of that you must have seen
things that we can't even begin to
imagine much less fully comprehend but
I've come a very long way to request
that you impart some information to me
if you can he paused again as if waiting
for a reply that never came the gate
Guardian merely stood in the same
defensive unwavering stance tell me
please how much do you know about the
Scarlet King by this point in time
although the foundation was yet to
realize Dr Robert Montauk was slowly
going insane his investigations into an
anomalous entity known as The Scarlet
King were gradually corrupting him as he
tried relentlessly to quantify exactly
what this entity was and how great of a
threat it posed little did Montauk
realize that in trying so hard to Define
and comprehend the being he was
inadvertently fueling its power the
Scarlet King was an interdimensional
warmongerer an embodiment of hatred and
chaos and Dr Robert Montauk was slowly
falling under the king's influence upon
hearing the tiny human figure utter his
question the immensuke guardian rebuted
with another single word psychic command
one it had never been recorded giving
before Witness
as if his increasing instability and the
creeping influence of the Scarlet King
hadn't made Montauk feel bad enough he
instantly felt sick there was a searing
pain behind his eyes like he was staring
directly at the sun accompanied by a
nausea that made his head spin it took a
moment of enduring the horrific
sensation before he realized what was
happening the guardian was trying to
show him something rather than give any
information on the Scarlet King verbally
scp-001 was imparting a psychic Vision
on to Montauk a memory of events long
past the answers he saw a warning or
perhaps all three the vision showed
Montauk a time so long ago that it
couldn't ever be forgotten for there was
barely anyone alive to remember it in
the first place it was eons in the past
long before the comparatively recent
dawn of humanity a time only spoken of
in the dust and blood tablet an artifact
of the daveite civilization some of the
earliest worshipers of the Scarlet King
himself and there marching up to the
entrance of Eden was the crimson-clad
Eldritch Abomination and a horde of
Horrors with him according to the story
recorded in the dust and blood tablet
this would have been much earlier in the
life of the Scarlet King perhaps even
before he assumed his now Infamous title
back then he would most likely have been
known as his original name of kantra one
of multiple siblings born when the tree
of life was planted and thus created all
life in the Multiverse but being the
only one of his siblings cursed with
awareness knowing the pain his existence
brought him comprok would eventually set
out on his lifelong mission to destroy
all of existence across every Dimension
and he started by killing his siblings
consuming them to claim their power for
himself around this time in prehistory
the being that would one day become
known as Scarlet King didn't quite
possess the power that he would several
Millennia later although that's not to
say he was an unformidable force of
Destruction fueled by his singular
hatred for existence his vow to destroy
extended to the tree of life that had
caused him to be along with the tree's
Creator and all of their Creation in
other words everything in the Multiverse
all of creation if you will so what was
the Scarlet King doing there so long ago
at the dimensional doorway protected by
the gate Guardian well beyond the
boundary between it and the rest of the
infinite Multiverse lay the supposed
Garden of Eden while it is unknown if it
is in fact the same Eden referred to in
the Book of Genesis is Up For Debate
especially among the foundation but at a
glance even through the gate it
certainly does look like a paradise the
space is filled with Lush vegetation of
astronomical size populated by a number
of beings that seem to resemble the gate
Guardian itself and they are protected
by its watchful caretaker are two trees
one is thought to be the tree of
knowledge that Eve was tricked into
eating an apple from during the Book of
Genesis the other however Bears an
unknown type of fruit and is widely
believed to be the tree of life now back
in the Modern Age there's never been a
conclusive link between the Tree of Life
mentioned by the daveites and their
barbaric civilizations Legends regarding
the creation of the Scarlet King but the
fact that so long ago he and his most
feared generals were bearing down on the
gate guardian's position defending a
garden where there was known to be a
tree of that description well it all
seems rather conclusive now alongside
kakarak were six of his Seven Daughters
each one of them a fearsome Abomination
much like their destructive father as
they approached not one needed to
exchange any words with their Angelic
protector of Eden the gate Guardian knew
what these monsters were here for they
would stop at nothing to pass through
his gate and uproot the Tree of Life the
progenitor of all living beings in all
of existence even though it was early in
cataract's career as the rampaging
interdimensional warlord he so is he was
as steadfast as ever in his goal to
annihilate every corner of creation
every Dimension every parallel plane of
reality every single pocket of existence
across Infinity they'd all come undone
if he burned the Tree of Life pulled it
out at the roots and splintered it until
nothing remained to The Once and Future
Scarlet King that the same tree had led
to his own tortured existence it was the
source of his suffering and it had to be
destroyed the only thing standing in his
way was a figure as colossal as camparak
himself wielding a flaming sword
Boom the psychic voice of the gate
Guardian it was like a doorman standing
before a group of Rowdy teenagers trying
to force their way into a movie theater
except these Rowdy teens were the
Scarlet King his horrifying daughters
and the forces he had already amassed
since its Creation The Horde stood ready
waiting for the commands of their King
who they thought would gladly lead the
charge as they marched on the Garden of
Eden to begin the destruction of
existence but that's not what happened
usually the Scarlet king would never shy
away from a fight preferring to lead the
charge when it came to a Slaughter
instead he commanded his first daughter
to commence the first attack on the
protector who stood in their path on her
foul father's word activity took her
horde and charged at the guardian what
she and her forces lacked a numerical
Advantage ativic more than made up for
in her knowledge of War she hungered for
it sought Dominion that was her seal
after all and yet in the face of this
impending Onslaught the gate Guardian
remains still rooted to the same spot it
had as always he would always be
standing in a number of ativic's minions
burst into flames the very fabric of
their crude formed separated on a
molecular level as they were
effortlessly rendered into nothingness
still the gate Guardian hadn't appeared
to move an inch had exerted no energy
despite the damage it had done to ativic
and her forces in defense of Eden as his
first daughter screeched and held in
despair at the decimation of her horn
her children the Scarlet King decided he
needed to better understand his opponent
with a wave of his clawed Crimson hand
the king commanded his next daughter
agroller to send forth her own Army in a
tidal wave of night nourished creatures
agor sent her horrific children into
battle she possessed a far greater
quantity to do battle on her father's
behalf perhaps eichhard even believed
that was the Scarlet King's plan with a
greater number of her forces over her
sisters maybe she would be able to
overwhelm the guardian but even as her
own children began to be vaporized the
closer that they got to the gate Agro
had no idea she was little more than a
pawn being sacrificed so that kantra
could learn more about his imposing
Angelic enemy another of the Scarlet
King's Daughters a being known as unquip
was the next called up to contribute to
the unfolding battle although to call it
a battle under cells just how easily the
gate Guardians seemed to be eliminating
the oncoming forces without even moving
while an out-relief frail seeming
creature anhuit's primary strength over
her sisters was a Proficiency in Magic
her innate ability to warp and reshape
reality around her it was that power
that had caused her father to be wary of
her viewing Anthony's abilities as a
threat to his leadership and so kanthrak
had her crippled and all her children
leaving them unable to overthrow him but
still loyal to their King obeying her
father's command perhaps out of the same
loyalty or fear that he would harm her
and her children further if she
disobeyed unwee unfurled her magic she
reshaped the world around them making it
so that the passage of time moves so
much slower and that was what revealed
to the Scarlet King his enemy's greatest
strength in combat the gate Guardian had
so far been able to obliterate both
ativic and now akhora's forces without
seeming to move but it wasn't by
standing still it was moving just much
faster than the blink of scarlet King's
multiple eyes now that unhoid's magic
had slowed the passage of time the gate
Guardian could be seen during battle as
aggarh's atrocities spilled towards the
angel to try and overwhelm it it
effortlessly blocked the oncoming
attacks with its sword everything the
Flaming blade connected with instantly
evaporated bursting into atoms as they
were practically cleaved out of
existence by the gate guardian's Mighty
weapon even with time slowed to a crawl
The Towering Wing protector of Eden only
appeared to be moving at an average
speed but when time flowed normally
without unquipped manipulating reality
the guardian was simply too fast to be
observed resisting the urge to dive
headfirst into the fight himself the
Scarlet King knew it would likely lead
to his untimely demise he refused to
accept that it could not happen but he
still had yet to amass the strength he
would need as he continued his Ascent so
while time was slowed to a crawl and the
gate Guardian was still engaged in
combat with agoro's forces he turned to
another of his remaining daughters
adista if the Scarlet King and his
forces couldn't get past the guardian
they could still try to get to the Tree
of Life while the protectors Focus was
diverted adisan Unleashed a wave of
pestilence sickness and disease spewing
from her in a cloud of vapor heading
straight towards the Angelic garden and
Eden's entrance Beyond The Scarlet King
knew this latest attack wouldn't phase
or weaken the gate Guardian he hoped the
foul smog would instead pass through the
Gateway itself into the garden as adisad
sent forth her power blood and Ash
soaked the landscape around them all the
plants outside the entrance to Eden
withered and died shriveling and
decomposing as the disgusting fog rolled
towards the gate it washed over the
guardian whose form only seemed to Glow
brighter as he repelled the pestilence
it was as if it didn't even need to
think about it still focused on
finishing off the rest of the oncoming
Army as its glow intensified so did the
fiery sword that the gate Guardian swung
with ease and finesse flames burst from
the blade the encroaching fumes Catching
Fire along with the air it's yourself it
ignited in a wave of fire a defensive
Inferno that repelled this latest attack
but for a brief few moments while time
stayed slow before unsweets hold on
reality inevitably broke the king had
sent forth atilif of all his spawns she
was the most reserved keeping mostly to
herself never speaking she and her
children could change their faces and
forms shift into anything or anyone and
walk undetected through the Multiverse
and now her father was employing her
incredible stealth abilities to slip
Behind Enemy Lines while the gate
Guardian was finishing off the remaining
Onslaught from conch Rock's other
daughters it was as attilift Drew near
creeping unseen closer and closer to the
entrance keeping the Scarlet King out of
Eden that the Guardians seemed to pause
it slowly ominously turned its huge head
tilting until it was looking directly at
atilif if its expression could be scene
maybe the gate Guardian would almost be
impressed that someone was able to sneak
past it after all was a feat that no
other being in creation could ever hope
to accomplish but then again with its
steadfast conviction and dedication to
its protective Duty maybe it would have
looked upon adelift with anger with a
cleaving swing of its scorching sword
the gate Guardian unfurled the tidal
wave of fire that engulfed everything
around it not just attitude
All the King's Daughters that had
attacked so far along with every one of
their own children were instantly
obliterated they were all reduced to
empty vacant spaces where they had once
been their atoms separated by the
Searing swing of the guardian's weapon
the devastating Blow by his adversary
did little to deter the Scarlet King
from his mission he was still set on
destroying the tree of life and no loss
was too great in his pursuit of
destroying existence he barely cared
that four of his own daughters had just
been unmade by the guardian anwhit was
still there Clinging On to time as if it
were a thrashing animal the Scarlet cane
could simply make her restore her Fallen
sisters and their forces he had lost
nothing but had held back for too long
and slowly drew his own weapon out of
thin air wielding a sword that was as
blood soaked as the Guardians was hot
the Scarlet King locked blades with the
one being standing in their
both the ancient Angelic Defender and
the attacking Eldritch Abomination were
evenly matched every one of their
vicious strikes against the other met
with an equally strong parody a weapon
of extreme all-consuming heat block
swipes from a sharp serrated edge that
matched the Deep Red that would be
forever synonymous with comfrock the
force of their two swords clashing and
striking each other was so great that it
rippled out from their one-on-one fight
the landscape around them was flattened
wiped clean of any remaining plant life
that hadn't already been destroyed by
the forces of the King's Daughters
despite having acquired nowhere near the
power he would thousands of years after
this fight the Scarlet King was still a
formidable force in single combat and
yet the gate Guardian seemed incapable
of tiring or weakening still standing
strong against the onslaught even after
wiping multiple armies out with its
flaming sword the guardian was still
able to hold its own against the Scarlet
King
who was Furious enraged at being so
close to the tree of life yet unable to
get past his Angelic adversary he'd need
to be stronger faster even more ruthless
than the warlord he already was despite
unwards slowing down time the king and
the guardian were at a stalemate time
that was it the Scarlet King needed more
time withdrawing from the fight he
realized that this was a battle that
could not be won by sheer Brute Force
alone his mission to destroy all
creation to get to the tree of life
would take cunning deception and more
time if he let it the gate Guardian
could easily kill comp Rock its flaming
weapon could cleave him out of existence
and that would end the king's torment
but it wouldn't be enough a death would
be unsatisfying knowing that the rest of
existence would go on after he was gone
the Scarlet King couldn't accept that it
wasn't enough so we did the one thing
nobody would expect of him he made a
deal with a gate Guardian it was an
action still fueled by his infinite
hatred for all existence his yearning
for total chaos the Scarlet King knew
that one day an event would arrive where
the guardian and the other beings like
it in the Garden of Eden would spill
forth and deliver judgment on this world
and when that Rapture happened the tree
of life would be undefended the Scarlet
King Bartered with the guardian that he
would Retreat for the time being so he
could spend eons amassing more and more
power than when the fateful day arrived
the gate Guardian would allow him into
Eden to destroy the Tree of Life while
it and its Brethren were busy conducting
the Rapture halting their fight the
Scarlet King offered a crimson claw to
the gate guardian's burning hand
returning to reality from the intense
Vision still feeling sick at what he had
witnessed Robert Montauk looked up at
the still silent 4 the gate Guardian did
you do it
he is desperate to know more through his
obsession with the Scarlet King did you
tell him yes did you make a deal there
was no answer from the guardian just a
single word that echoed through
montauk's fractured mind
now go and check out scp-001 the Scarlet
King dust in Blood and scp-001 the
Scarlet King Darth Vader begs for Mercy
for more of the multiverse's most
monstrous monarch